what's that moment like when you're
sitting in that chair and they call your
name what happens in your brain I've
everything just stopped it's kind of
shriveled for a limit because they
didn't it doesn't feel real it doesn't
feel real no but now it is I mean it's
definitely real it's not fake this also
means that there's got to be a call
tonight to be like we got to get the
second system off we got go right what
do you what do you say now I'm gonna see
what Jed sing and what he comes up with
wise what he wants to do you know have
some chance this year I'm sure for the
people who haven't seen there's a lot of
television out there for the people that
haven't seen The Bodyguard explain to
them what is it that makes it great I
think it's the chemistry I think it's
the chemistry thank you very exciting I
think it's the characters are all and
there's gray zone there's moral
ambiguity of not being good or bad mm-hm
that's what makes this show really
interesting I think to watch is because
everyone's really human no one's kind of
defined yeah yeah yeah
now you also are you were sitting on the
heels of rocket man that's coming up you
have to get ready for that too but um do
you have any more shoots for rocket man
or any kind of things you have to do
where you could take your Golden Globe
and show it to the boys well Titans here
tonight so it's just great really you
guys go ahead hang out tonight
yeah and you bring your Golden Globe
with you all right do that thing's heavy
it is isn't it it's crazy
but it doesn't matter does it what does
this mean as far as like people try to
always put it into context their career
and what it means to win a golden glow
but right now wanting this Golden Globe
what does it mean to you as an actor you
know who's questioning yourself and
you're always trying work out if you're
good enough or if you're deserving
enough for ya and most of the time you
kind of always have this fear that
someone's gonna tap you on the shoulder
and say hey I find you a you know an
actor you're rubbish you can do so this
was something for myself comes with
being a hey look other people who think
you can do so you need to kind of
believe that do where does that go
cuz I've maybe saw that far ahead yeah
you have it my wife already texts
because she loves the show in that
I got turned on to the show because she
was watching it so um it's a Golden
Globe win for the Frasier household - so
thanks in Galatians man this is
fantastic thank you very last ik program
go out and make a hell of a season -
thank you so much well yeah thank you
very much all right
congratulate
[Music]